I appreciate you calling in last last we
spoke you were beginning to feel the
sensation of a special season in New
Orleans and it's the first 10-win season
since 2013 your third year in the league
do you still feel the same way about
this team right now yeah I feel that we
we control our own destiny this year we
talked about being able to win our
division you know over the next two
weeks something you have to keep in mind
but at the same time we've got a heck of
a game coming up this Sunday and that's
where all the focus is okay now what
happened between these two teams the
last time was there any bad blood
essentially out there Cameron you know
we talked about a team that you think
that your team is face twice a year you
know you wish that you could win all of
those games but at the end of day you
know they know they know us they know
we're gonna do as we know them and we
didn't do enough support and we didn't
execute enough of what we needed to do
to complete to get the win now asking
about bulletin board material I'm
usually loathe to do that to be honest
with you Cameron and you being a Cal guy
know what you know what I mean by when I
say that that you know I'm loathe to do
it because that implies that you
wouldn't play your hardest in a game
that means so much that said as my
caveat to the question seeing what
Devonta Freeman tweeted out aints after
the game and going at it with your coach
is that something that's gonna be
discussed in your in your locker room
this week no I mean at the end of the
day we know that we didn't play the best
game that we should have between em to
take over that game when you talk about
what Devon takes with men tweet it out
and then retracted I put that in the
spoils of war category and what honestly
was gonna fuel me more so is being able
to get after Matt Ryan being blasts him
and uh you know putting on B claims to
win this game so I'm excited to work all
overtime now on
filming breakdown Matt Ryan and Devonta
Freeman and Coleman and putting locks on
the receiver core and really getting
after their entire offense so you know
we'd love to turn around and say hey
this is the this is where we could start
division or you know even though we do
that campus falling against that well we
still live in pasture just a little bit
while longer with Cameron Jordan of the
New Orleans Saints here on the Rich
Eisen show I had Steve Smith on the show
the day after that that Thursday night
er and asked him about Sean Payton
getting that flag at the end which
essentially wrapped the game up for
Atlanta and asked him how he would feel
if he was a teammate on that team and he
said he took it that that was show that
the coach cares so much that the coach
is the type of guy that is in the
trenches with the players would that be
an accurate assessment of how it was
received in your locker room I mean Matt
during the day you know what app that
flag happened was was something that you
know clearly affected the game but at
the same time it's just that you know
he's got as much passion and love for
the game as we do and you never you know
you never try and look back and you know
trying hard on the negative things that
have happened in the game I can only say
you know I had one more interception one
will turn over one more sack cause
fumble that's something that could taste
again we can't change anything but a
Tweedy
approach the game okay Cameron Jordan of
the New Orleans Saints here on the Rich
Eisen show did breeze bust out a matumbo
analogy based on the number of batted
balls that you and the rest of the
defensive line add did I hear that
correctly possibly I mean you know when
you talk about five s is deflected in
the game that's a pretty high number but
one was not counted because there were
two points I just learned that in fact
that's probably just as important either
more important than just a regular third
day because points were on mine so so I
guess greed is good when it comes to the
number of batted balls that you're
looking for here right you know I've
been I've been throw it around fun terms
but I feel like I
cemented my status as a BB so are you a
shutdown lineman is out you're saying
[Laughter]
you know your words not mine I just feel
like you know I should be I should be
able to walk between three rooms in our
meetings just to pop in how about this
can I leave you with something on this
front about the end our comp we're not
ending our conversation but just while
we're having this conversation on this
front how about next time you bout one
down you do a matumbo finger wave what
do you think right right I'm really just
gonna be like you know next time about
one down I'm gonna run over to Marshawn
I'm like yeah we get PBS
you could do that too and what does that
young man added to this defense Cameron
lolani
yeah his tenacity take the field I mean
the way his prowess of how attacked
their wide receivers up in the Jets had
a pretty decent my receiver I think and
you know the number 11 but you know in
terms of what Marshawn would ever do
completely spent that kid out of the
game that's special when you're able to
put him on a quote-unquote number-one
receiver and know that you know that's
gonna be a bad day for him that's that's
exactly to me of the defensive line I
wish you know that would have been
turned made petty puck pump-fake at
least one figure you know four or five
better balls down you make him pump fake
once or twice you know really sit in
that pocket but he didn't okay yeah you
know that's something that we have to
make Matt Ryan do the shirt and it's
again a big game here for week 16 before
you go and look at more film on the
Falcons what did you think of the end of
the Steelers and Patriots game the way
that also played out I don't know is the
Patriots doing Patriots like I have no
idea I apparently my football knowledge
is not up to par because I thought it
was you know whatever I thought I
clearly you know the rest got
differently so instead of you know
falling into this whole conversation of
which the case was not catch I thought
Mike Thomas had you know gonna catch it
in the end zone right but we didn't
catch that call you know in your
previous that's pretty much less still
delay at Carolina Carolina Saints game
over at Carolina the year before but
again it's it's a pickle matter we're
the zebra stripes would you have a
problem if the rule was changed that a
receiver leaping for the endzone in the
process of making a catch that that if
it's if the ball is knocked out after
crossing the plane of the goal it's
still a touchdown would you as a
defender have a problem with that uh
yeah sure you would okay okay alright so
before I let you go here Cameron Walter
Payton Man of the Year Award nominee for
your team how could people get involved
with your charity work in in New Orleans
and one of the reasons why you are
nominated for this prestigious award a
lot of questions that's just I just
stepped up to the challenge and my and I
you know privacy of trying to put this
in building putting running they're
trying to inspire you know the next
generation and not only it's better
people you know I've never lived without
always use different avenues you clean
with I've never once in my hey I want to
be the face of something but if that's
what it takes if that's what I could do
to expand my outreach but that's really
what this motivation here I've got to my
attention that getting so much for the
what I am doing
well good luck against the Falcons and
and good luck in the in the award
perhaps you could be one of those
fortunate ones to pick up the award in
your uniform on the field of the
Superbowl that you're playing very very
rare
have that so I hope that's what if
that's what you wish for that's what you
get Cameron oh yeah thanks for calling
much appreciated always at cam Jordan 94
of the New Orleans Saints in a huge week
taking on the Falcons here on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience